[Music]
good morning Hank it's Thursday August
2nd and I'm in an airport because I am
on my way to Los Angeles I'm going to
the conference of a society of writers
I like conferences and I like writers if
he owned societies but I can get behind
them so I'm pretty excited about this
thing except the only problem is that
instead of having it right here in
beautiful Indianapolis Indiana they for
some reason insist on having it in Los
Angeles
Hank congratulations on another
brilliant song I thought that one might
have been your best yet it actually
inspired me to do a song of my own it's
quite drugs it's quite jokes in here
although running my AC is screwing up
the atmosphere it's quite jokes Hank as
has been pretty well documented on this
video blog I'm not a big fan of
traveling via airplane in fact there's
only two things I like about airports
part-full and video games what I like
about pretzels is that they're not so
much of food in and of themselves so
much as they're a vehicle for salt and
butter I think there was one of the part
of your song that I thought was really
interesting and that was the part where
you started to make out with the fan
when you were making out with that fan I
kept thinking to myself don't stick your
tongue out don't say good tongue that
don't stick your tongue a tough ticket
on that don't stick your tongue out and
I'll tell you why it's because when I
was in college I saw a guy stick his
tongue into a fan and it hurt at the
time we were playing a game of I will
Hank I don't know if I ever told you the
rules of I will but it basically went
like this I would say I will lick the
cat for would you stop talking
heightened security measures guy I would
say I'll lick the cat for $5.00 and then
someone else would say I'll lick the
count for $4 and so on until someone
licked the cat for a nickel I can't
remember the exact price we ended up
paying the guy who stuck his tongue into
the box man but it was something in the
neighborhood of like $8 and so he was
all like he was all like and then after
he got done screaming here is like
Jeremiah our God and speaking of
potentially having to stick your tongue
into a box fan somebody's about to get
punished and tragically that somebody is
not you the extraordinarily hard-working
nerdfighters in my pants have found
textual communication that I apparently
made to you on January 11 2007 the
actual textual communication was
something like Hank you should feel free
to edit this if I had said Hank should
feel free to edit this I would have been
fine it's the you that killed me stupid
by the way I'm in Denver now but it's
the exact same because all airports
everywhere are the same it's like they
all call each other and say hey did you
get the airport concrete and all the
airport authorities are like you guys
got the gray walls everybody got the
gray walls the the silver window panes
good anyway Hank I look forward to
reading everyone's punishment
suggestions remember if the Yeti vetoes
it I don't have to do it and I'll see
you tomorrow